[Music]
there was a process
there was steps to get to the end result
now you have operators that hit a button
influence
without further ado let's get on to our
second operator
lion enemy drone incoming starting the
clock
well we were in atlantic city in the pro
league finals and my monitor broke
in warm up and i still got two assists
by just pressing four on my keyboard
without having a monitor in an fps game
because i had a broken overpowered
operator what makes lions so powerful
well a lot of people say just stay still
but that's not easy when you're getting
flashed or pushed or jackled or rushed
by a shield yellow just stood still
just now and what happened just a few
years ago
rainbow six siege was a game that had to
claw its way out of an early grave
hackers game breaking bugs and busted
mechanics threatened to turn the game
into a failure
but ubisoft believed that siege could
survive the developers made much needed
changes that fans were asking for
breathing new life into the game
both casually and competitively
matchmaking connectivity
all those aspects are absolutely
critical to the
experience of the player so putting that
investment
now on health is ensuring that in the
long term
we're having a better and smoother
experience for the players with a
growing player base
and steadily increasing viewership siege
was well on its way to becoming a major
esport
until the devs broke the game big
brother coming in for overwatch
in operation chimera ubisoft added a
lion to the game
and that kickstarted one of the biggest
balanced nightmares in siege
history in the competitive scene i still
think that jackal or dokeby were
stronger back then
but lion just had more of a visual
appeal
to people it felt stronger seeing
through walls or
wall hacking is a pretty common cheat in
games like cs go
but lion brought wallhacks to siege in a
real no
cheats way his kit let him literally see
through
walls you get spotted on a drone they
lie on charged and then the
entry fraggers would find them so there
was like literally the same thing
on repeat thrown someone in you see an
opponent lion presses number four
and then the guy was entry fragging
kills him and he couldn't do anything to
fight back either
i mean they had exact information on you
and you had nothing on them
now lyon wasn't the first character in
siege to have wall hacks
both pulse and iq have limited access to
tracking players and gadgets through
walls
but lion took things to a whole new
level a lot of people have
very strong opinions online think that
he's completely overpowered that his
gadget
is way too strong and that overall is
just not going to be good for the game
lion's gadget an aerial drone called the
ee1d could scan the entire map and
revealed any defending player who moved
during the scan to the entire attacking
team and he could do that
three times around a lot of people were
saying
remove like make it so he only has two
instead of three scans
but that won't really do anything
because the reason that you got
frustrated was because
you felt that one scan you don't care
about all the ones that didn't impact
you
you're correlating your death to i can't
do anything because i was lion scanned
and he had a wallhack
lion was so broken on release that he
completely upended the meta
all of ubisoft's careful balancing went
out the window alright ubisoft
we need to talk about lion you've
designed an operator
that can literally give your entire team
wall hacks
if used correctly which is not too hard
to do
if you're playing with a coordinated
team just come in with blitz or jing
and it's an easy win there's no surprise
he's actually seeing
a hundred percent play in pro league
understandably
having your entire team's positions
revealed to the enemy team was
kind of frustrating to play against and
nowhere was this advantage more
devastating than in
pro play giving only brian a live
nvk testing his control key and
well get taken out there he's just
cutting off this rotate he's going to be
scanning out one of the players that is
the vigil
target acquirer now magnet knows exactly
where he has to cut off
he's also getting lion also getting ying
detected by the e1d neo cleans him up
raphael using the smoke and candela
combo is just going to push right in
they'll have some covering fire as the
artillery of glass stands in bathroom
and look at that raphael they will just
bully them vitality
sweeps into the site and will get the
plant down both pinari and uno will now
need to retake
and bibu on the zofia cleaning up
line was introduced during season seven
of pro league before pick and ban was
brought into the game
which meant that teams had to play him
there was literally no reason not to
though some teams saw this as less of a
problem and more of an opportunity
in line with their hyper-aggressive play
style team liquid went all
in on lion's game breaking mechanics too
late for penta psk gets one more two
left alive kento remember
low on health as eunice will hold the
back angle the buck has already opened
the wall in the back and team liquid
a flurry of the two at the end they are
one round away from being crowned
the new champions but lion wasn't only
broken when you built strats around him
turned out that he was so hopelessly
busted that you didn't even need a
working
monitor to win with him well we were in
atlantic city in the pro league finals
and my monitor broke
in warm up so we were warming up i don't
remember against who it was
but my job was to play lion even though
i hated him as much as i did
so the the admins came and took my
monitor off my table
and i still got two assists by just
pressing four on my keyboard
without having a monitor in an fps game
because i had a broken overpowered
operator
i literally he took my monitor he pulled
out the plugs on it
took it he lifted it off the table and
then i'm sitting there looking at nick's
well penguin screen and i say okay he's
throwing someone i'm pressing four now
and then the guy can't move and then we
get two kills from that like i'm sitting
in spawn no monitor
i don't see anything all i do is press
one key fans demanded a nerf to lion
because
there was pretty much no counter play as
soon as he started his scan
it was pretty much over for the enemy
team
oh my god
but a diversity breeds ingenuity teams
started to adapt and
find new ways to combat the menace some
teams started picking mute more often
trying to disable lion's gadget
but others found more innovative
strategies
the easiest way for you defenders to
avoid getting tagged by the scan is to
simply not move your feet
you can rotate in place aim down sights
fire your weapon
and even change stance without being
detected but the second you move your
feet
you're tagged but not moving was easier
said than done
sure you were invisible to lion's scan
but you were also standing still in a
fast-paced shooter like
siege what makes lions so powerful well
a lot of people say just stay still but
that's not easy when you're getting
flashed or pushed or jackled or rushed
by a ship yellow just stood still
just now and what happened he still died
because the jackal track was on him and
they were able to push in so you've got
two abilities at that time you've got
one ability that prevents you from
moving which is a lion's ability
then you have jackal's ping which even
if you stand still
still shows you where you are and then a
third just needs to come in to clean up
the kill that is what makes lions so
powerful because there really
isn't much you can do to combat it and
i'm gonna just be blunt with you guys by
just
saying oh you can so easy to counter you
just have to stand still
that's only gonna happen against really
bad kids and higher levels
that is not going to happen you are
going to have to move and you are going
to guarantee get well hacked because you
have to move otherwise you lose the
round
line's abilities were so powerful that
they completely broke the fundamental
rules of siege
there was a process there was steps
to get to the end result
now you have operators they hit a button
influence
that's what i meant when i say we're
straying towards the
overwatch mentality of hit button
influence round
which is exceedingly low skill ceiling
it's just it's just it's it's down here
you know and it just keeps getting lower
and lower and lower but i don't think
that they're doing enough in terms of
balancing
the game out to be still an fps game
with that little extra bit of spice
that we had in the beginning but now
it's more of a
yeah it's a utility simulator which
utility can counter which utility
in 2018 siege esports was blowing up
but line being so broken threatened to
destroy everything that ubisoft and the
community had worked so
hard to build a lot of good teams were
moving around quite a lot right and some
of those weaker teams
couldn't handle that so as soon as you
had a lion on your team because you got
the full wall hacks and that you
literally just had to
well you saw his outlines you ain't
where his head was and you shot him
through the wall
or through the floor or through anything
you couldn't do anything about it
so it was very oppressive to these
better teams with more skilled players
but it was really really good to use
superstructure team
but in the end it was just such an
abrupt
operator for for everyone that was
playing the game
it just made it boring to play and a
lion ruining actual matches wasn't the
only problem
he was so broken that he was creating an
air of toxicity in the scene
i'm gonna play it and so is the guy on
the other team right and now
we're upset at each other for playing
the the operator that we don't like to
play against
um then there are people trying to come
up with this whole like
gentleman's agreement where you don't
play it but that doesn't work as soon as
as soon as there's something to win
people want to win in season 8 ubisoft
added pikman to the game which helped
keep lyon out of pro matches
in fact he had a nearly 100 ban rate
which
pretty much put an end to team liquid's
lion centric reign of terror but despite
the community uproar ubisoft was in no
hurry to make any changes to lion
himself
it took a long time it really took a
long time i think that's that's the one
thing where
people are completely fair to be upset
um if they do decide to change stuff it
has to be faster
eventually though the developers were
forced to take action lion is an
operator that we faced a unique problem
with
we know that he is overpowered and today
the dev team is ready to act on it
starting next season we will put lion in
a
competitive foreign team which means
that the players will not be able to
pick lion
in our esports programs our esports
programs are the weekly go for the
challenger league the pro league the
miners and the majors but
it was all too little too late the
three-month quarantine doesn't do
anything for us
in the terms of nerfing the operators
that are too strong
ace is super oppressive melusi i can
tell you melusi is super oppressive
and there's nothing we can do about it
because we can tell them this or that
and that and it's gonna go in one ear
and out the other one
what they could have done with lion was
make it uh take away his drones take
away other forms of intel
because intel is the strongest thing in
siege and always has been
so remove some intel from him or make it
so he has to constantly be on it
right um all of that would help and the
pessimism didn't end with lions
quarantine
every operator released afterwards was
obsessively scrutinized
and i feel like most of the operators
that have been released well
they have been overpowered when they're
released
and then they are toned down a bit and
they're toned down a bit
and then eventually they're fine but
there are some operators that use are
way too strong and we still see that
today even though if it's not like as
prevalent and
like they aren't as strong as lion was
when he was released
we still see a lot of operators that are
way too strong eventually
lion was nerfed and released from his
quarantine a move that was pretty
unpopular with some players despite the
changes
lion's terrifying wall hack may have
been replaced by a location ping
but he was still a force to be reckoned
with i mean i would kind of put lion
i would move him down from being like
the most toxic operator like breaking
gents now
to like being that like second tier
where he's like not
breaking gents but he's like annoying to
play against kind of
still once the dust settled some
community members agreed that maybe
declaring lion the death of siege was
a bit of an overreaction you use your
his gadget to
try to either make them stand still or
move and get the outline and then your
team's push
that's gonna be one way that you can use
them to clear rumors and in that
situation
i have no problem with line i don't
really feel like that's
op at all because it requires team
coordination
you know just because you spot a rumor
in those early round situations it's not
a free kill there's still a lot of
options that that rumor has
yes it's very powerful for a roam clear
but it's going to require a
coordinated team to take full advantage
of it at that point in the round
it definitely changed the game and it
was less enjoyable to watch but i don't
think the panic
truly fit um what what happened there
i think we were a little too quick to
react and i think we've been that with a
lot of things
frustration and balance are two very
different things
and i think that's where we kind of
screwed up as a as a community
we looked at it and went this isn't fun
so therefore it's overpowered and there
is nothing that can be done
we can't change the way we play we can't
work around it
and then we just all write angry
messages instead and hope that it
changes
but the rest of the community isn't
willing to forgive they remember that
lion was a plague
and for eight painful months he took the
joy
out of playing siege thanks for watching
if you want more content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages
you